I was an infantryman with the second
Battalion raw Resort Fusion layers there
was about 50 of us that flew out and 11
including myself come on unharmed so
that was really hard and I'll be honest
it took me about a decade you know I
left in 2010 and I sort of started to
get my stuff together well really to be
honest joined the academy you probably
hear this a lot it might become blase it
changed my life man so powerful such a
powerful environment to be in and now
your fun time in bubble today what did
you make last night turnover was 61k
that's one thing one gram it's crazy
when you say out loud it's been
happening so fast I don't really get a
chance to reflect but now saying how
loud yeah and lots happened
you did it you made it to winners on a
Wednesday feels good feels good
absolutely it's a big milestone this is
very proud to be here thanks for having
your house yeah that's a huge everything
we grew up not too far apart as well
that's right that's right best city in
the world God's Own
So you you're killing it on the on the
property side of things and like a year
ago you didn't have any coffee
experience what are you doing and why
are you so successful how are you so
successful
uh well it was hard at the start I'll be
honest but I mean I've just followed
everything you've taught me to be honest
I feel like in the early days if you if
you give me 10 points of things I should
do probably easily digested maybe seven
of them and when something wasn't going
right and I'd call a mentor
uh it would be the like the eighth ninth
and 10th thing I'm like yeah somebody
did say that actually and start doing
basically everything I was taught and
it's just worked like a dream like the
the formula Works 100 you know and now
your fun time in property full-time yeah
then you had your best month ever last
month what did you make last night last
night turnover was 61k ask one thing one
grand
crazy numbers
and what sort of profit is that it was
only about half profit but good yeah
yeah it's about 30 Grand in a month how
what were you doing
will last one for the two JVS as well
um which I'll get properly agreed I'll
get someone else to say I can get you to
JV put your money into an essay that
I'll find yeah so you'll put your money
in
it'll usually be a premium as well it's
expensive to JV with me I'm doing things
well I've got a team with me that are
being paid to we did all the management
it's fully hands off to use
I'll give the investor about 40 of the
profit and I'll take 16. that gives me
then some left to give you up between
the team and have the work yeah you know
the workload uh the distributed amongst
us and um but what I've started doing
lately because I wanted to get a bit
more hands off with the rental rents is
I'd sell another fraction then of what's
remaining to another investor
so rather than just selling the deal
with 3K I'm like selling percentages and
then keeping a percentage too so
basically you've become a master at
finding deals and you're finding all
kinds of your brrs flips red to Red
service accommodations in Birmingham and
outside of Birmingham and then you're
just selling them partnering and and
making money all of that yeah it's
working quite well I can't believe 61
Grand turnover it's almost it's almost
too good to be true
now and again I get fed up and I go you
know what let me check my bank I said it
for a joke before and now I actually do
it now they're going to just check the
bank and yeah it's not that bad but if
it was probably very good so do you do
you keep companies yourself as well I
mean how many properties have you I've
got five but I'm upgrade yourself yeah
but I've only got liabilities on two of
them my very first one I came to myself
and I've got like little bits of
liability inducted about but most of it
is um like I've got somewhere I got one
for example that's zero liability The
Profit okay I'm like a consultant on
that one right so I'll just Consulting
help and advise and stuff
yeah so what has been the key to your
success because this is all quite it's
only in the last I mean it's now been
about a year I think since we met yeah
about a year and I just just uh saw the
mark of my full 12 um 12 months of the
academy that was on the 6th of May
so um
yeah I mean I think the key thing is
like you told me early on uh add value
and um
I was just doing that I was just trying
to help people like I've mastered
through the courses watching the courses
watching the videos again again and
again and again making notes come to the
courses too
uh in person
and understood rent to rent understood
deal finding
and
was able to advise people then add value
that way and get my name out and stuff
so build some credibility and now I I'm
like literally I've got so many people
on a JV with me it's insane like a lot
of people are JV they're probably easier
for me to do a JV right now than it
would be to sell a deal but another
interesting thing isn't it yeah is you
just walk into estate agents
and you'll walk out with a deal things
are green ninja of taking on I mean
you've had so many like lease option
agreements that people have just been
like yeah we'll do it you seem to have a
brilliant way about you of actually
securing deals getting like a video
closer that's what most people struggle
with you know most people they
understand the theory and and all this
and they have their spreadsheets and
their right move links but actually
closing the data is what you're gonna
say how do you do that like if if I'm a
landlord and you're trying to secure a
Richter man what are you saying to me
how are you closing them I mean I'd
highlight the okay and this is something
I say to people as well when I'm trying
to add value and help and advise them I
say you need to understand that we are
offering a good service and this is just
me repeating your words here you know
but um you need to understand that you
are offering a good service there's
management companies out there that do
less than what we do and they charge a
fee we're going to Stage your house your
furniture is a gift and it's completely
hands off we handle everything and we
pass the fees on to the clients so
explaining that in that way is a huge
plus also I will always love to bring up
section 21 tenants rights yeah for
anybody who doesn't know that's
obviously uh you know it's difficult to
get people out of the house to throw an
AST contract whereas of course on the
company like I always explain it to be
like a phone contract and that if I
don't pay you on the day what happens
with your phone bill it gets cut off
it's the same with us so I'll explain
things in that way and I'll give them
like I'll go over my contract with them
and show them that it is like that and
it is fair that we will guarantee you
the rent every month
and I want a thousand pounds to my
Birmingham city apartment and you know
that you could rent it out for a hundred
pound a night and you could make a few
thousand pounds minus your expenses you
could be left with a thousand pounds
profit right I'm a landlord on the
ground so what are you gonna do what's
the first thing you're going to follow
there you're gonna book a viewing about
how are you gonna I do do a lot of work
on the phones to be honest and I'll tell
them up front before I book a view and
I'll let them know it's for a company I
never just say did you do a company let
and and pause I'll explain to them who I
am and what I do and
um I think a key thing as well is to
explain
who are you going to be housing that's
the key thing and always say to people
like get relationships get some
credibility through relationships with
recruitment agencies with the NHS with
whoever's relevant to you in your area
if you live in a small town I'm sure
there's a uni at least there'll be
people who are visiting their their sons
and daughters are in uni get some sort
of credibility to say I work with
Nottingham University or something and
we hired the parents who are coming up
obviously they're good people they've
set their children to UNI whatever sort
of credibility you can get goes a long
way to connect with businesses and
people in the area get get a hook and
then when you're speaking to ages and
animals because actually speaking of
such as such a business a particular
company goes a long way that yeah that's
nice so how do you deal I mean you're
somebody you're I I I know you a bit
about your backstory I know you didn't
do breathing in school well
um I know you're not massively into
paperwork academics and it's not your
thoughts you're very good at getting
deals and closing how did you do with
all the paperwork and the contracts
making sure that all the legalities and
the compliance is correct when in this
business because there's a lot of
compliance in in the property industry
how do you get around that I think I've
done all the mentors heads in calling
them all if I didn't have that I never
would have got this far I'd have felt
lost honestly it's it's like having
you know my own staff being able to call
any Department I want to click whether
it's business planning legality I've got
a
um a department I can call through the
academy and a book of mental call
usually within no time someone will get
back to me and give me all the advice I
need I've got a good team around me too
that help with a lot of stuff like all
the admin sort of stuff I delegate all
of that I don't do any of that I'm just
on the phone doing sales
uh you got people that like work a few
virtual assistant yeah I've got not a
virtual I've got a physical assistant
um Bradley who lives in fanbridge which
I'd never heard of before it's four
hours okay let's get to Burgers we've
only met a few times uh that was pretty
random to be honest you just fell in my
lap I was posting deals
and uh he just kept messaging me saying
how are you doing this how are you doing
this and it was so persistent in the end
I was hosting a dinner in Birmingham
which at the very second month and
um
again which was off your advice get your
investors together and I do do that and
that's quite fruitful and I invited him
up to one really nice kid impeccable
manners well presented very intelligent
and so um I partnered up with him and I
think he's been doing three and a half
Grand a month in just commissions from
his help I'll give him a cut of each
chalamic he's in 19. wow I mean he's
done three and a half Grand a month for
the last few months it's a really good
what's the day now able to start
literally employing people helping other
people you know through your success in
your company it's crazy when you say out
loud it's got a bit blase to some degree
because it's been happening so fast I
don't really get a chance to reflect but
now saying how loud here and lots
happened and also when you put on a
dinner so what are you doing so every
time you sell a deal to an investor
every other month you'll put on a debtor
and you'll say if you ever bought a deal
through me and you're one of my
investors I want to take you out for a
dinner yep and then all these investors
that have bought for you coming down
seeing you why do you do that
uh I'm you know I'm quite a social
person anyway but when you said it
before
um I thought that is a good idea you
know I enjoy that sort of stuff yeah and
uh it just really works I've had people
tell me that's the best night of my life
and I'm just like wow I can do even
better than that the next time you know
yeah it's just really good I've had JVS
through it I've had I've sold deals for
it so there's business that gets done
it's quite a social thing you know
um more than a business sort of thing
but uh it's it's been really good and
also what I thought is let's say you
let's say someone some doctor from
London buys a deal pays you five grand
for a deal cool back
you've got to invest in that
relationship because if you just think
oh God I sold a deal to say no
inviting for dinner take them out that
credit would have been another deal
another a dealer before maybe I won't
enjoy adventure with you or maybe he
knows and loads of other investors so
it's almost like a very good use of time
putting on a dinner and inviting all
your investors in one go also if you've
got any investors that aren't happy with
you
it gives that opportunity to start
actually my deals like Antigua and then
finally we put it right like obsessing
over your investors obsessing over your
customers I think is is a great thing
what's been the biggest challenge that
you've had there in in running your
full-time property business probably
would be the admin sort of thing um
coming from a very professional
background you know I mean I didn't pass
anything in school at all I think I've
got an X I didn't know that was a thing
you're gonna get an X I know no mate you
can get an X an X that sounds worse than
anything yeah it's pretty Grim I just I
didn't really care in school at all you
know I always knew I'd join the military
and uh I just sort of laughed it all off
you know
obviously I wouldn't advise that
um I just knew though that school and
uni and the nine to five sort of thing
wasn't for me yeah so adjusting now to
this type of life has been quite a
contrast I know I'm glad that you had
serious struggles and when you did your
Academy interview we were saying this
guy's all either going to be extremely
successful or this is going to be
terrible yeah well it's looking like it
was it was the format I mean you're
doing extremely well you're inspiring
other people reaching people like I
might not be able to reaching
um what what was it about property that
got you wanting to wanting to do this
why did you want to get
I mean just the old saying you know safe
as houses and I think everyone's
considered how nice it would be to be
able to buy a house and have lots of
houses but you think
the way that the school and the banks
teacher you need to do a mortgage and
have good credit all that sort of stuff
and a lot of people especially with my
background don't have that mate and
that's not an option and probably don't
even know anybody who's done that to go
to for advice let alone to have someone
in your family who's doing it or do it
yourself it's quite abstract
um
so yeah it is nice for me to be able to
you know make myself relatable to people
what's your Batman then like before you
join the Army whereabouts are you from
what was live like
uh well I lived in handsworth which is
not a nice area in Birmingham I know it
very well yeah it's a bit of a bad Town
um a lot of my close friends have you
know been put away now on Long jail
sentences and
not done much with himself other than
that and uh that sort of a thing that
you say like watch who you're around and
as I noticed a lot of things I think you
say some of them like very many very
many powerful points some of them can go
over people's heads but like I said it
could be the eighth ninth and 10th point
that when you really start doing it
things will start to come together for
you because for me when I started to
separate from people that I knew weren't
any good
um you know things really changed a lot
and uh the background I come from I
would like to be able to help people
from that background because I want to
help yourself first you know you have to
invest in yourself whether it's your
time where you're spending your time
with where you spend your money all that
sort of stuff but uh I I initially I
joined the military uh quite young to
get away from all that too and uh after
that finish that pretty much went back
into the same
same circles but uh when did you serve
in the military what was what was your
role what was it like I was an
infantryman with the second Battalion
Royal refusaliers it's called regiment
disbanded now uh we got beat up pretty
bad in 2009 Afghanistan in the peak of
the war the worst hot spot for all the
what we call uh contact combat when it
kicks off there was a lot of that
um
I think there was about 50 of us that
flew out and 51 and 11 including myself
come on unharmed as I remember on the
chopper flying home I looked around and
I was like I don't recognize any of
these boys the raw substitutes but
you're so busy
you know as I was on the chopper leaving
I was like they've got all these people
where's my original
lot you know so that was that was really
hard and then uh coming home after that
it took me a long time man to get right
to be honest it took a long time like
you can't do that sort of thing for
months and months I'll end it was
supposed to be six months with the fs7
the chopper got took out it was supposed
to take us home so we got stuck for an
extra month eating spam and noodles and
warm water that tastes like chlorine so
we had that for uh for seven months and
coming home everybody just just left it
was like I said it was a really rough
bit it was literally the peak of the War
disproportionately uh more uh contacts
there than any other period so that was
really hard and I'll be honest it took
me about a decade
you know I left in 2010 and I sort of
started to get my stuff together uh well
really to be honest I joined the academy
you probably hear this a lot it might
become blasé to you now but it changed
my life man so powerful such a powerful
environment to be in and that's why I
renewed it to me was wasn't a second
thought even if it had been 12 Grand
again I'd have done it again uh without
a shadow without I think you could
charge double and it'd still be worth it
it was it's outstanding the value and
it's so nice it's uplifting to be able
to add value to other people now I know
things over the stripping machine guns I
know something that's actually useful
for the real for the normal World other
than you know
dark things let's just say
um
it's really really uplifting to be able
to help people and advise people
sometimes someone will ask me something
and as a management like wow I can't
believe I know this stuff I can't
believe I'm able to tell people about
tax and contracts and lease options and
buying houses and no that's not a good
Roi I'm like who am I you know but like
it's all through the education I've had
you know so how do you deal with like
you know imposter syndrome what you feel
like I check the bank mate I get that a
lot and I I I do just check the bank and
I'm like okay it is real it is real but
I do I feel that quite oftenly like who
who am I what is my phone rings we want
advice I'm like who am I forging to ask
me about property stuff you want to buy
houses for hundreds of thousands you're
asking me like who am I so I I haven't
really got over that impossible you just
check the bank because ultimately money
is a certificate of that exactly paying
you money it's because they're saying
you're valid exactly the values there
yeah yeah the value zip that's rough I
mean I can't obviously I can't even
imagine how tough that'll be go do what
you've been through your background I
know how yes
what did your friends and family think
when when you told them you were getting
into property and you joined the academy
like was it it's completely even world
isn't it very very different I don't I
don't really at the top of my head I
can't really think of it in my family
that's even been to uniman so when I
said I'd spent 12 Grand on a course it's
a lot of money and uh they were just
saying that's stupid you're an idiot
whatever you're doing and all that sort
of stuff and now I think this the sort
of slowly getting it when I'm taking
them to houses and be like what this is
one of yours yeah and the scene that
that business is happening a lot it's
sort of becoming a bit more real now but
I think it's still quite surreal yeah
because they're very familiar with major
I mean so they know just as well as as I
do that it's a massive contrast I've
gone from the life I was in to what I'm
in now I think even for them to this day
it's still a bit hard to believe you
know yeah and I read when you first
joined the academy you were kind of it
was two things going on what like yeah
you have Academy property and business
but then in the early days sometimes you
talk about the slit back in the old
environment and we'd happen to be
calling you up kicking your ass where
were you you weren't on the mind about
Mastermind yeah yeah I have to leave a
shout out to bequea who gave me the
final call that give me the like the
final push to get to get back in she
called me man it was like 11 o'clock in
the afternoon this is before I got
really serious I had something to the
academy but I hadn't really really got
serious it was like 11 in the afternoon
I've been out late and doing stupidness
and I was in bed and I was embarrassed
because she could tell she's like you're
in bed I was like yeah what's happening
and she was like you haven't been doing
a masterminds the course is like where
are you you're not doing this like and I
was a bit embarrassed and I thought man
I gotta stop it's one or the other now
it's like the crossroads you know yeah
thank god um you know thanks to him
obviously I chose the right way so here
I am today and but that's the thing like
that's called accountability right there
I mean you can't force anyone to be
successful but what you can do is you
can order them through account you can
give them all the tools and and and
whatnot and now can you imagine going
back to your sort of your old life or do
you think that's never going to happen
now
absolutely not no I feel sorry for
myself even a little bit my former self
and people who are still in that sort of
environment because if you don't know
you don't know it's easy when you know
yeah you know but
um a lot of people just haven't got that
knowledge so I mean I think it's a great
thing with the crash courses
to come and be around people who are
doing I remember my first crash course I
met people who were already exist in
landlords
who would come to the course and I
thought but you're already in property
so if you need help well I'm definitely
in the right place then I'm coming along
people as well yeah quite a lot yeah so
many that were doing really well in in
life just Engineers that were doing like
80 grand a year but they weren't happy
with what they were doing whereas I'll
meet a single person on the academy in
property that's not got a big beaming
smile on their face and that's another
reason I love doing the dinners because
it's nice to be around winners not
around positive people you know yeah
yeah and we obviously the academy
dinners as well yeah which are better of
course yeah no I thought it was
different in it and then you've got
their little clusters and everything but
no I think for me the biggest thing
that's going to make people successful
is being in the right environment
because you've heard the other purpose
says before I say if you've got a plant
a house plant and it's not blossoming
you don't blame the plant you chase the
government you put it in the satellite
you water it because environment will
determine your results in your life
exactly and exactly you know you were
like a social experiment
wrong environment wrong Circle and then
plucking you out and dropping you in a
new environment yeah and um you know
you've absolutely blossomed what what's
your thoughts about helping other people
that are so from your old life circles
hands work maybe people that are also
from you know the military how do you
what do you think the best way is to
help them get on the property start and
help them become financially independent
like you are
I mean I just think I have to join the
academy man I I really I think about
this a lot you know and um
I don't want to feel like I'm pushing it
down people's throats but I really do
think it's not a question of can you
afford it you better do whatever you've
got to do to afford you can't afford not
to because once you what's the other
option do a mortgage for 25 years on one
house that you pass that to your kids
and they're going to be taxed again what
is it 40 inheritance it's horrible like
I've learned ways to plan for an
efficient tax in there and and all that
sort of stuff and you know it's it's
something I think about a lot is how to
help people in the military and people
from my background as well and um
definitely something I want to go into
I've actually got a few ideas that
perhaps we'll talk about afterwards
maybe about um you know some exciting
stuff I want to do and that sort of from
some videos I need to start being a bit
more active a lot of people tell me
everything especially pulled me aside
the other day one of your crash courses
because I still come to those just
because I just I know the stuff is you
know it's selfish stuff to me now I've
done a year in the academy and being
active in property but I still come just
because I love
yeah just because the buzz you know
and at the environment of the people I
love it but he'd be said to me the other
day he said that bro what's going on I'm
your instructor so I need to be a bit
more active on the socials and I've
thought of a few ideas like little
social experiments you know inspired by
your Financial Freedom challenge but
going out into the city center and
proving that your environment
is key like what good is a diamond in
the desert yeah it's a bottle of water
but a bottle of water in the High Street
isn't worth that much because there's
they're everywhere for a quick yeah and
I thought about going into town with a
sign just saying like an old you know
property info for free and people are
probably just think it's some sort of
scammer keep walking past well they did
but did you see my experiment in Hyde
Park exactly yeah stop moving the
straight offering to give them a free
house and not one person thought in the
contract because they thought was it's a
scab where's everybody said that at the
Academy now oh man who would have all
been jumping up and jumping though as
well as soon as people say to me signing
it because you know for me training
people to be confidently independent to
particularly but it is a genuine mission
for me like I'm in my life I give my
life to it but at the same time it's a
business is an investment but if there
wasn't if it was free
people would would involve that weren't
serious there's no kind of like barrier
to entry so you know it's it's a really
interesting one I I have to say if you
don't pay you don't pay attention it's a
fact it's a fact it definitely puts a
fire under your backside to to motivate
you and it's it's worth it anyway like
you know you'll you'll make it back but
people pay three times that for uni to
go and make you know the same per year
they're lucky if they're paid off in
their life yeah you know what I mean
it's it's it's it's a no-brainer for me
to sell your first deal because that's
something you'd be very good at selling
deals yeah I'll be honest with you I was
very slow starting yeah I think for the
first three months I had all the excuses
I was still involved with you know
another world let's call it
and I was holidaying and just doing
everything I could to not have to do
this to be honest right you know until
that when that final Crossroads came and
I realized yeah pretty much credit to uh
think it was around December it was my
first sort of deal was actually like a
JV right the first deal the first it was
a beautiful property on queslet Road in
Birmingham yeah Quizlet Road right by
Asda really lovely brand new referred
property and I sold my Carmen I have to
sell my car I had no money left other
stocks would beat me up I'd invested
pretty much my last into the academy uh
you know Jack and the Beanstalk there
but it was it was a wise choice and um
yeah and I forgot about that you know I
sold my car and just to get this to get
to pay the rent and deposit one and then
I was literally I had nothing you know
you said something he said say yes now
forget the needs I was like and it was a
good price
for the property I needed make a lot of
money and I thought someone will loan me
the money someone somewhere and there
was a fella called Dean Dean Martin
great guy ex-military herself very very
good man horrible man him and his wife
Lorna
borrowed me the money
for uh I met them at one of your courses
yeah and I met them on your courses and
they're borrowing the money to furnish
the house and um a painting back now
twofold he's very happy we're gonna do
more together that was my first one and
then that was like December and then
January I sold my first deal which was
surreal I remember thinking it just it
was a real man that was the day I was
checking the bank a lot I just couldn't
believe it it was real I think a lot of
people have that too I think it sounds
too good to be true it sounds like a
scam it is it is a little too good to be
true but it's true yeah female but the
thing is there's a lot of investors out
there that want good deals they're
wealth they've added all the time to be
going out in the rain on a Tuesday
afternoon to negotiate itself agents
cancel on at the last minute they live
too far they're tumors they've got their
businesses and their jobs so they'll
happily pay three four five thousand
pounds to a deal sourcer to do all that
donkey work for exactly and that's where
I come in yeah there's people like that
there's people who I know that just
don't naturally do very well on the
phone or in agencies they've got all the
knowledge but they're just not really
yeah they need confidence they need
someone to negotiate the price down and
and you'll be able to jump on the phone
within 20 minutes not 20 grand off
they'll pay you two grand for that pool
they're not paying you for that for your
time they're paying you for the value
from bringing them anymore come more
valuable and you become rich
some of your biggest lessons that you've
learned if you were to talk to your
younger self
from from a year or two ago just before
you really started getting into property
and becoming successful what would you
what advice would you do
I think I say take the jump because a
lot of people like you've got the voice
in your head turning to do one thing and
another thing to do another like the
right and the wrong let's just call it
but um
it's easy to make excuses not to do
something that you really you want to do
or you know might be successful but you
miss 100 of the shots you don't take
you've got nothing to lose by trying no
one's going to come around and kick your
head in or like you know you're not
gonna get put in jail for trying to do a
business and trying to do so just try
just have a go like it like I said it
took me a good few months to really get
rolling but I was persistent and stuck
at it and it worked and I think again
the environment man watch the
environment you're in because if I'd
have been in the wrong environment I
probably would have quit after a couple
of months I went through like I think
about 16 uh I was getting a lot of yeses
in the early days and I'd turn up
to a viewing and they'll say yeah we'll
send you an application and they never
did and I called Tyrone I said so what's
going on man like I'm getting all these
yes she said he goes what do you think
the problem is and I said you know I do
I ride my motorbike today's video I turn
up in my levels and it was like brown
didn't change your clothes you know
dress a bit Swire and he's he's helped
me a lot to do it it'd be massive
massive help I think I've already done
his head in the amount of time I rang
that guy Ibrahim is a great guy
um I remember some weapons everything
used to constantly where did my
challenge of evidence he was always
getting he'd be rude to him and he's
from St Lucia black guy and yeah maybe
not there's some people that might be
being racist whatever I said at least
dress smart take the baseball cap off
yeah
give yourself the best chance yeah yeah
you know at least and um you know now
he's a property billionaire
um and you've got to do that you've got
to be presentable and and and and
constantly monitor how can you improve I
love what he said about just try so many
people they don't even try what's the
worst that can happen if you start a
business what was it about it it doesn't
work out then you go back good job but
you're in a job anyway you know exactly
exactly if you had people being like
discriminating against you whether it's
because of you not not even necessarily
you're right it might be because of the
fact that you've got a handsworth accent
it might be because you know you're
you're um like I had people discriminate
against me when I got started because of
my own age I was out there the estate
agents William the deal it's 17 years
old
you know so if you had that or have you
ever have I have because I've had so
many no's but to be honest I just I
don't focus on it really because I've
had so much success now it's hard to
look at the losses you know
um but in the early days if I have to
really think about it in the early days
it probably was how I sounded how I
looked and in all fairness to those
people I probably wouldn't have trusted
me either with the keys to my house
because I was turning up in like rugged
motorbike clothes and yeah you'd heard
my bike coming from a mile away it's a
big bike and it's just not a very
professional job I mean now I put the
shirt on and pull up in the car you know
nice shoes
yeah but
um yeah I think there's a listen whether
you're black white in between gay trying
whatever you might be whatever sort of
end of the spectrum you wrap there's
going to be someone who likes you out
and someone who doesn't like you and I
mean like I said before on a mastermind
to you as long as you remember uh you
asked about what how am I so confident
to keep pushing and I said look
I think we could get in your range now
and drive around throw in ones or 50s at
people and someone's going to be some
people are saying oh that's great look
at these guys this is really lovely and
some people are going to say who do they
think they are yeah so no matter what
you do not everyone's going to like it
man but you've got to keep trying yeah
it's funny because when I started out in
business I used to drive around like a
Ford KA 400 with a fan car we're dancing
and brought that up and people used to
discriminate against me because love
it's in my card right now man
idea we're buying of him and then now
I'm successful when I got nice fantasy
cars if I turn up in a too expensive car
I struggled to negotiate because they're
thinking oh what's wrong here you
weren't trying to negotiate so you're
rich so actually sometimes it's better
to go into Ford Focus than it is but
you're right some people some people
won't like it because of the Kaluga
t-shirt and it's really about numbers
game if you look at some of the best
football players or basketball players
in the world or golfers they'll be
missing a lot more shots from the
average person but they're just taking
mugshots you know in fact I think that
Winners lose more than losers lose
trying more yeah trying more absolutely
I fail your way to success go for no
because
absolutely another thing you said a long
time ago there's problems no matter what
you want Rich problems or poor problems
you know like you said that's that's a
rich man problem we've ever heard about
your car's too expensive yeah you know
what I mean so my tax feels too big I'm
gonna shrink it that's a good problem to
have man yeah you always get a problem
there's always gonna be something
everything's hard in life it's hard to
be rich it's hard being poor it's hard
being married it's hard being saved
not having kids everything's hard you
just gotta choose what life do you want
what hard do you want and I'm so glad
that you've chosen the life of a
successful businessman
the inspiration and the Rippling
effective positive that you have in the
world as a result of your hard-working
dedication I'm excited to cause those
ripples too I mean anybody I could add
value to I'm more than happy like I said
it's uplifting for me and it's surreal
it's surreal and uplifting to be able to
advise and help on this sort of subject
matter it's it's it still feels quite
new to me although I've been going for
like a minute now and I love seeing new
people coming in and I can relate to
them I remember when I was just starting
off and the sort of little struggles and
tips and ways I tripped I could stop
them from tripping maybe so it's really
refreshing you know being part of the
community is all about like every week
when we do the Mastermind it's not just
medium and answers someone will have a
problem and then it's like I'll put
Karen in all this Buddhist or that
person then you know it's awesome what
would be your final words of wisdom on
this interview right now
I would say
definitely take the jump take the jump
do what you need to do to be around the
right people be learning the right
things
and and do what you know is right just
do the right thing do the right thing
for yourself put yourself first if you
want to help your family you want to
help other people you need to be in a
position yourself first be able to do
that sort of put yourself first in a
sense of learning how you can be more
valuable how you can give more value and
you can be more of an asset and um
everything else will just fall into line
then I'd say I love that bro you
properly inspirational in the link on
the description I'm gonna put a little
Link in which is the one pound crash
course but we come come to the crash
course for a pound what would you say to
someone that's thinking about clicking
the link and spending a day with me on
the one pound crash course a pound it's
the best pound you'll ever spend I mean
that that pound I've come to crash
courses and got deals through crash
course since I've got a property now
great one through that but I would say
to anybody else who's thinking of coming
it's again it's not a case of can you
afford it time wise or financially it's
a case of you really can't afford not to
it's uh all the videos you see all the
people you see saying they're making
some so much money it's one thing
watching a video you need to come in
person and really see and look something
in your eyes and hear them tell you how
much money they're making what their
life was like before and really feel
firsthand the contrast and the the
upliftment and the joy that people get
from being involved with property
investing you need to be there in person
and to really feel it respect brother
cheers I'll see you around my brother
thanks come down to the one bar crash
course where I can dance everything I
know about property into one day tickets
below one pound Liberty space in book
now I'll see you there
[Music]
thank you